[Musique]
bonjour
alors j'ai une grande nouvelle pour vous
il y en a qui sont déjà au courant dans
la salle
c'est la fin du monde
pour être plus précise c'est la fin d'un
monde
il y a eu d'autres civilisations avant
nous
est-ce qu'il y en aura après
ça va dépendre des
actions qu'on prend aujourd'hui
alors je sais pas vous
mais moi j'ai peur
j'ai peur que cet été le village d'à
côté décide de nous couper l'eau
j'ai peur des incendies autour de la
maison
j'ai peur que mes parents ne supportent
pas la chaleur
bonjour rassure l'idée c'est quand même
qu'on ressort de ce moment ensemble avec
plus de légèreté et surtout une immense
envisager
je vais faire un petit sondage dans la
salle
lever la main ceux qui pensent qu'on
vivra mieux en 2050 qu'aujourd'hui
levez la main maintenant ceux qui sont
pessimistes quant à 2050
ok vous gagnez
on va partir donc de se ressentir l'écho
anxiété à savoir l'anxiété
vis-à-vis des effondrements écologiques
à venir
avec le mouvement de mobilisation
citoyenne qui s'appelle on est prêt que
j'ai lancé en 2018 on vient tout juste
de sortir un programme qui s'appelle
tu flippes
prendre soin de soi pour prendre soin du
monde
notre Manifeste c'est de dire que si
vous flippez c'est bien normal c'est
normal étant donné la gravité de la
situation
étant donné l'inaction des décideurs
et étant donné la répression de ce qui
agissent
et alors vous n'êtes pas seul à flipper
on est des millions à flipper pour notre
avenir
donc venez on transforme ces émotions en
action et ensemble on devient une force
immense
je vais revenir sur les différents
points de ce manifeste
la gravité de la situation pour
commencer
ça fait plus de 50 ans que les
scientifiques nous alertent et qu'ils
ont l'impression de crier dans le désert
en 1962 Rachel Carson sortait le livre
printemps silencieux pour nous alerter
sur les désastres des pesticides
en 1973 sortait le rapport mitose sur
les limites à la croissance dans un
monde fini
aujourd'hui
les scientifiques sont désespérés ils
sont révoltés
et ils ont créé le mouvement
scientifique en rébellion pour nous
inviter à entrer en désobéissance
le truc c'est que si on résout le
problème du climat on ne résout pas pour
autant notre capacité à habiter cette
planète
le problème il est plus profond
il est que nous nous croyons comme
maître et possesseur de la nature
comme disait des cartes
résultat nous avons aujourd'hui dépassé
6 limites planétaires sur 9
qu'est-ce qu'une limite planétaire
et bien c'est un seuil que l'humanité ne
devrait pas franchir pour continuer à
vivre dans un écosystème sûr à partir du
moment où on franchit une limite
planétaire on entraîne une mod une
modification brutale de l'écosystème
terre et on entre on entre dans des
zones d'incertitude
d'imprévisibilité que les scientifiques
ne savent plus comprendre
résultat aujourd'hui en plus du climat
vous pouvez voir qu'on a dépassé la
frontière de la diversité génétique
changement d'utilisation des sols les
nouvelles entités dans la biosphère la
perturbation du cycle du phosphore de
l'azote et de l'eau douce
merci des cartes
alors
cette fin d'un monde elle ne va pas se
faire en une nuit
vous avez peut-être l'impression qu'elle
est lente qu'elle est invisible et pour
autant elle a bien lieu en ce moment
même ici et partout donc si vous flippez
c'est normal et la bonne nouvelle c'est
que si vous flippez ces seins
c'est sain parce que ça veut dire que
vos mécanismes de survie fonctionne
et si nous sommes vivants aujourd'hui
sur cette planète c'est que nos
mécanismes de survie ont bien fonctionné
pendant des millénaires
donc votre peur aujourd'hui elle mérite
que vous écoutiez ce que ce qu'elle a à
vous dire votre part elle peut être
votre meilleur conseillère à condition
qu'elle ne se transforme pas en angoisse
et en panique qui vous paralyse et qui
vous rend manipulable
et alors vous n'êtes pas seul à flipper
aujourd'hui 75 75% des Français
éprouvent de l'anxiété liée à
l'environnement
et la bonne nouvelle c'est que ensemble
on peut devenir une force immense
selon les sociologues
erikach chénovet et Maria Stéphan
il suffit que 3,5% d'une population se
mobilise pour renverser un système
alors
renverser un système c'est une chose
encore faut-il avoir imaginé par quoi on
le remplace
lutter contre le nouveau monde se fait
en même temps qu'agir pour le nouveau
alors tel que vous me voyez aujourd'hui
j'ai vécu ma longue traversée de
l’écondité
en 2005 2006 j'ai vu deux documentaires
qui s'appelle une vérité qui dérange
dans le corps et la 11e heure sur la
mort des océans
et j'ai eu une prise de conscience sans
retour en arrière possible
au fur et à mesure où les annonces
scientifiques tombaient
cette prise de conscience devenait de
plus en plus aiguë et je me questionnais
sur ma place juste dans ce monde
jusqu'à ce qu'en 2015 je décide de
bifurquer
je travaillais alors chez Canal+ et j'ai
décidé de démissionner
pour créer l'écosystème que j'imaginais
depuis plus de 10 ans
à savoir un écosystème qui coordonne les
sachants les artistes et les faiseurs
l'idée c'est que les scientifiques ont
besoin de haut-parleurs pour faire
entendre leur message
et quel meilleur au parleur que les
artistes
seuls capables d'émouvoir des millions
de personnes
et une fois que le spectateur est ému et
envie de passer à l'action et bien
l'idée c'est de lui proposer des actions
très concrètes qui ne peut appliquer
dans sa vie ou sur le terrain aux côtés
d'activistes d'ONG et d'entrepreneurs
sociaux
cette écosystème au début je me sentais
pas légitime à le porter
et finalement
ça a marché pas j'essaie de le faire
porter par d'autres qui comprenaient pas
ce que j'avais en tête et j'ai fini par
écouter les amis autour de moi qui me
disait que si j'étais capable de porter
cet écosystème moi-même
donc je me suis lancée
et c'est comme ça que son nez on est
prêt et imagine 2050 en 2018
la raison d'être dans les prêts c'est de
mobiliser massivement les citoyens pour
une société plus respectueuse du vivant
et de la justice sociale et la raison
d'être d'imaginer 2050 c'est
d'accompagner les leaders culturels
apprendre conscience des grands enjeux
de société et les accompagner pour
qu'ils incarnent ces nouveaux récits
dont on parle le temps
quand je parle de leader culturel je
parle aussi bien d'artistes que de
journalistes de patrons de studio de
cinéma de télé de jeux vidéo
alors
aujourd'hui mon econxiété moi-même on
vit une relation plutôt amicale et je la
remercie parce qu'elle m'a mis sur le
chemin de l'action c'est grâce à elle et
aussi grâce à mon énorme amour de la vie
qu'aujourd'hui je me consacre à la
métamorphose du monde via les
imaginaires parce que pour
créer un nouveau monde il faut d'abord
commencer par l'imaginer et alors pour
imaginer ce nouveau monde je m'appuie
sur la théorie du donut de Kate house
donc le donut vous connaissez j'ai vu
que vous en aviez à la cafette
c'est donc ce beignet très appétissant
avec un trou en son centre
et le donut de Keith hour prend en
compte aussi bien oups pardon ça c'est
la semaine d'après
vous avez rien vu
prends aussi bien en compte les 9
limites planétaires dont je parlais tout
à l'heure
que en son centre le plancher social
nécessaire pour vivre dignement à savoir
pour tous l'accès à l'eau à la
nourriture à l'énergie etc
alors est-ce qu'il est pas trop tard
vous allez me demander est-ce que c'est
encore possible de créer quelque chose
de nouveau
et bien oui et c'est ça qui est super
excitant
on est donc pas avant Fifty Shades of
grey
mais on est dans 50 000 nuances de bleu
et rouge
la question c'est pas de savoir de
manière binaire si on va y arriver ou
pas
la question c'est de savoir ce qu'on va
réussir à sauver
ce que vous vous allez réussir à sauver
où est-ce qu'on va placer le curseur sur
ce code barre du climat
où est-ce qu'on va passer le curseur en
termes de biodiversité
où est-ce qu'on va placer le curseur en
termes de protection des océans
vous demandez
alors
tout à l'heure je vous parlais de la
peur
il y a quelque chose qui s'appelle
l'effet tunnel
qui fait que plus on a peur plus le
champ de vision se rétrécit et plus on a
l'impression que les possibles diminuent
et à l'inverse plus l'imagination
augmente et plus le champ de vision
s'ouvre et la peur diminue
parmi les deux régulateurs les plus
puissants de la peur il y a le lien
humain et l'imagination
le lien humain parce que plus vous avez
d'alliés à vos côtés pour faire face à
une menace plus vous sentez fort et plus
la peur diminue
et les Alliés ce sont des personnes avec
lesquelles vous partagez un récit commun
c'est robe Kings
qui dit dans son livre et si
qu'à partir des années des années 90
pardon
notre potentiel a imaginé a commencé à
dégringoler alors même qu'aujourd'hui on
en a plus que besoin jamais
on a aujourd'hui besoin de cette
imagination collaborative pour un
prendre conscience de ce qui se passe
imaginez des solutions à la hauteur des
enjeux et se mettre en mouvement vers
ces solutions
je vais vous donner des exemples de la
puissance de l'imaginaire
pour le meilleur ou pour le pire
je commence par faire le pire par vous
parler de Edward Bernays
qui est le neveu de Freud et qui dans
les années 20 a posé les bases du
marketing contemporain en s'appuyant sur
les théories de son oncle
en 1929 une grande marque de cigarettes
lui demande de réussir à faire fumer la
moitié de la population à savoir les
femmes alors que c'est très mal vu à
l'époque pour une femme de fumée
et alors ce que fait Edward Bernays
c'est qu'il organise un grand défilé
très médiatisé à New York avec des
mannequins qui ont dans une main une
cigarette et dans l'autre main un
panneau torches of freedom les flambeaux
de la liberté
Bernard avait compris que la cigarette
et le symbole du pénis masculin et donc
de l'émancipation de la femme
le lendemain la main des terres
d'autres exemples
la série le jeu de la dame
a déclenché un véritable engouement chez
la gente féminine pour le jeu des échecs
la série le bureau des légendes a fait
exploser le nombre de candidatures pour
devenir agent secret
et certains se disent que Barack Obama
et volo devoirski doivent en grande
partie leur élection présidentielle aux
séries 24 heures chrono et le serviteur
du peuple
un autre exemple que j'affectionne tout
particulièrement c'est qu'il y a
quelques mois des scénaristes sont venus
nous voir pour nous demander de les
accompagner sur une histoire de blackout
il n'avait que des images de guerre
civile qui leur venait en tête et ce
qu'on a fait c'est que on a choisi au
contraire de les accompagner pour
nourrir des scènes d'entraide et des
scènes qui ont réellement eu lieu et si
on l'a fait c'est justement pour nous
préparer lors des catastrophes à agir
avec solidarité en nous tendant la main
les uns les autres
on parle beaucoup de nouveaux récits
aujourd'hui mais on a encore quelques
difficultés à les incarner donc on a
fait un travail assez colossal de
synthèse de scénarios prospectif c'est à
dire de scénario d'anticipation fait par
des experts pour regarder quels étaient
les points de convergence et les points
divergence entre ces rapports
3 grands scénarios se sont dégagés le
scénario business asusuels le scénario
la technologie va nous sauver et le
scénario de la sobriété
vous vous doutez que peut-être vous
doutez peut-être qu'elle est deux
premières les deux premiers scénarios
nous envoient dans le mur et que seul le
scénario de la sobriété est viable et
nous permet de continuer à habiter cette
planète voilà quand je parle de sobriété
je ne parle évidemment pas d'alcool
alors aujourd'hui on a besoin des
artistes et des médias pour nous aider
pour nous aider pardon
à montrer en quoi cette sobriété peut
être désirable
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale les
Américains ont réussi à nous faire
désirer un American war of life
et aujourd'hui nous pourrions créer un
écological way of life
un mode de vie ou
nous visiterions notre rapport à la
réussite sociale
à ce qui nous rend véritablement heureux
est-ce que c'est vraiment la
consommation qui est capable de nous
rendre heureuse
non il y en a une qui dit non là
et si les artistes
prenaient une société de l'être au lieu
d'une société du paraître et si les
artistes prenaient une société du soin
des liens du lien à soi à l'autre à la
nature
et si nous revisions notre relation
sauvage
alors dit comme ça tout ça ça peut
peut-être paraître un peu bisounours de
prime abord mais je crois véritablement
que c'est ce qui nous permettra de
passer de l'écho anxiété à l'espérance
en mouvement pour reprendre le terme de
Johanna Messi
et j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous
c'est que l'action collective
au service d'un récit collectif ça
marche et ça peut générer des victoires
et donc faire un bien fou premier
exemple avec la première campagne on est
prêt on a réuni 130 influenceurs qui ont
mobilisé leur communauté sur leur réseau
sociaux pendant un mois
ce qui a permis de toucher des millions
de personnes grâce à cette campagne ce
qu'on a réussi à montrer c'est que
l'écologie peut être une norme sexy
c'est que l'action collective peut
rendre joyeux malgré la gravité de la
situation
et que ça ne sert à rien d'attendre de
se sentir légitime ou parfait pour agir
la perfection ce n'est pas de ce monde
à la fin de cette campagne de cette
première campagne on a mobilisé autour
de la pétition de l'affaire du siècle ce
procès contre l'État pour inaction
climatique cette pétition a fait 3,2
signatures
ce que ça a permis de raconter c'est que
les citoyens ont la capacité de faire
pression sur l'état en passant par la
justice
parce que ça a permis de montrer aussi
c'est que la nature peut avoir des
droits
et aujourd'hui ce domaine juridique
explose
alors ce que j'ai envie de vous inviter
à faire c'est ensemble
de sortir des dystopies décourageantes
de créer ensemble des utopies du site
de rejoindre ce grand voyage cette
grande aventure de l'imagination en
action
et tout à l'heure je vous disais que la
question c'était pas de savoir si on
allait y arriver ou pas
mais que la question c'était de savoir
ce qu'on a l'air réussir à sauver ce que
vous alliez réussir à sauver et bien
maintenant j'ai envie de vous demander
qu'est-ce que nous réussirons à imaginer
ensemble merci
[Applaudissements]